[Musik]
das ist der militärmusikfestival Rap
Blick von informationsoffizier John
Patrick Platzer ich melde mich zum
Dienst der Auftrag ist klar fürs
militärmusikfestival wieder viral auch
dieses Jahr hat mich das Bundesheer ins
Rennen geschickt klar alle Uniform doch
ich habe den Trip mit Platzkonzerten
gingen die Party lose machten 16 mal
Station für musikalische Shows in
Kärnten Steiermark Slowenien Salzburg
Tirol man konnte auch Informationen
übers Bundeswehr holen z.B gibt's
vielfältige Jobs manche sind und sogar
absolvierten versiert einen Ninja
Parcours die Militärmusik und flieg Herr
und hurra das ja Kommando oder ich hatte
selber 1 € fighter pilot bei den Schoß
mit dabei war du bist doch mehr Infos
heißt dieses Rap Resümee dann krieg dich
rein auf Musik und bundeswehr.at ich
freue mich euch hier in Kern zu sehen in
der 2 black Arena die Creme am 25 Mai
wird ein besonderer Tag mit einem
besonderen Länderspiel der besonderen
Art z.B kommen Abordnungen aus Slowenien
an auch aus Italien Montenegro und auch
dem Oman über 700 Musiker und innen am
Start Überraschungen parat ich komme
gerade ist den Vater das musikalische
nein das ist mega limitiert von Charge
Stürmer Chris Steger Autogramm Jäger
haben einiges vor auch Andreas Schager
singt was vor heldentinoor nicht nur
bergbauernbuam freuen sich dann vor
Glück wenn die entzückende Lederhosen
rockerinnen rückt aus dem Lesachtal
direkt zum Wörter sehen naschenwen
Melissa 10 von zehn Mensch ins Dunkel am
Start ist die Spenden sind wertvoll und
die Tickets in gratis also kommt vorbei
die Party Zugführer John Patrick Platz
und meldet sich
[Musik]